brooklyn beckham and nicola peltz are
married
the eldest son of victoria and david
beckham and the 27 year old actress tied
the knot at her family's estate in palm
beach florida ahead of the ceremony a
source told e.t brooklyn and nicola are
excited to get married and celebrate
their special day they've been planning
and prepping together adding the
lovebirds are quote very in love and
can't wait to take this next step in
their relationship their friends and
family are really happy for them we love
our kids and we want the best for them
before the couple found they were each
other's perfect match brooklyn
previously dated actress chloe grace
moretz for a couple of years but ended
things in 2018. meanwhile nicola was
linked to justin bieber in 2016 then
dated model anwar hadid for a year after
that
jumped to october 2019 and brooklyn and
nicolas whirlwind romance began i feel
really lucky the pair made their
relationship instagram official in
january and come june brooklyn popped
the question get down on one knee and i
start telling how much i love her and it
like lasted like five minutes and then i
reached back i got the ring and i opened
it i was like will you marry me because
i want to be with you for the rest of my
life like you're my best friend um and
she just like crying and i was like oh
no
well like and then she didn't answer me
for like five another five minutes she
just kept crying i was like is it yes is
it a no
it was there
it was a little bit nerve-wracking but
you stayed down there the whole time the
whole time
and since their engagement fans have
been getting more of a glimpse into the
couple's relationship what's my nickname
for you a baby baby yeah we call each
other the same thing or misses yeah cool
of my misses like not to me but if he's
talking about me
what do i love about you
everything
very kind to you
i cook you food whenever you want i make
the best tea because i'm english i would
say i'm a gentleman right i hold the
door open
yeah it's probably one of the many
things brooklyn's learned from his dad
and there's no doubt david and
victoria's 22-year marriage is a perfect
example for the newlyweds we've got four
amazing children um and
you know we work very hard both of us um
but nothing comes in the way of our
family and nothing comes away in the way
of our children um so they're our
priority but you have to make time for
each other as well you know it's an
important part but um you know we're
busy so we make it work
as a family we're sure brooklyn and
nicola are taking note congrats to the
happy couple